good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I met
all the misery of human life it's easy
to forget that there is much worth
celebrating and as we begin a new year I
thought it would be nice to start it off
with some good news
like for instance divorce rates in the
US have gone down every year since 2006
and are currently at their lowest level
since 1970
then there's pregnancy which from what I
can gather is not fun the global rate of
unintended pregnancy has declined
dramatically since 1995 when 69 out of
1,000 women had unintended pregnancies
in 2008 it was 55 in 1,000 women which
is good news because unintended
pregnancies can have all kinds of health
consequences for infants and for mothers
including increased infant mortality
which reminds me that infant mortality
is at an all-time low worldwide it has
dropped from 46 deaths per 1000 births
to 35 just in the last eight years now
of course you're worried that we're
gonna have like 70 kajillion humans on
earth but in fact when infant mortality
declines families have fewer children so
decreasing infant mortality actually
helps the overall population of humans
stabilize which is good because there
are already too many of you driving up
the prices to playoff tickets from a
hometown Indianapolis gold go into the
playoffs more good news but in more
important good news absolute poverty is
down worldwide in fact the United
Nations estimates that poverty has
decreased more in the last 50 years than
it did in the previous 500 so much for
the idea that colonization is good for
the colonized adjusted for inflation the
number of people living on less than a
dollar 25 a day has decreased from 43
percent in 1990 to 20 percent today now
most of that is due to gains in China
and India and Brazil however sub-saharan
Africa along the world's poorest region
has been growing much faster than the
world economy for the past decade now
inequality of wealth remains a huge
problem around the world but in the vast
majority of countries the poor are
becoming less poor also there is good
news for those of us in the developed
world in the United States cancer
mortality rates have dropped by 20% in
the last 25 years
why well mostly because people quit
smoking or died from smoking but also we
have better treatments and screenings
for colon and breast cancers and a bunch
of others then there's the internet
which is reaching more people at higher
speeds in the u.s. internet speeds were
up 27% in 2013 over 2012 in fact they
were up all around the world from
Guatemala 75% increase to Thailand 32%
so it's easier than ever for people to
stay in touch and to
elaborate it's also easier than ever to
visit one another while being herded
like cattle into a steel cylinder and
rocketed through the air remains one of
the least pleasant experiences that a
human being can have air fares have
dropped by almost 50 percent since 1985
you can also fly to more places than
ever before and it's never been safer
speaking of safe traveling let's talk
about cars for every 100 million miles
driven in the US and 2011 there was 1.1
vehicular fatality in 1980 that number
was 3.5 if you dig 1980 as your baseline
safer cars and safer drivers saved
60,000 American lives in 2013 that's
pretty great also things are getting
better for non-human animals well at
least the ones that we've domesticated
back in the 1990s 17 million cats and
dogs were euthanized per year in the US
now that numbers closer to 5 million
what else will the fight against malaria
is working with mortality rates down
nearly 50% in the last 10 years more
girls are attending school around the
world and the literacy rate for women in
their 20s has risen from 79 percent in
1990 to 87 percent today and in almost
every country on Earth you are more
likely to live to be old than you were
10 years ago you are less likely to be
hungry and you are likely better
connected to those you love
Hank 10 years ago we couldn't have had
this conversation because there was no
YouTube the nerdfighter community
couldn't have raised more than
three-quarters of a million dollars for
charity because there was no nerdfighter
community and of course this progress is
tenuous and much of it is unsustainable
with current technology but it's also
real and it's worth celebrating so
here's to a new year Hank may it really
and truly be the best one yet happy new
year Hank I'll see you on Friday